job creation in the in the Arab world
well you know I work for an innovation
and design company called frog and I
honestly believe that you know region
like the Arab world where it's somewhat
from a Western perspective underwraps
should go back to its core culture and
find a way to allow its people to begin
creating things that are truly Arabic in
nature and work towards brand building
small cottage industries much along the
ways that that Italy did post World War
two they stayed to their core they made
things they made high-quality things
they stayed close to their culture and
built the global brands and I think that
this is a way that the Arab world can
stay close to the things that they do
best amplify their culture bring
something to the world that is very
difficult to find and and find growth in
that way